Je vous présente Rabab ! Rabab c'est  mon éléphant rose personnel, et ça veut dire Babar à l'envers.
Je suis en train de commencer tranquillement l’emménagement dans le bureau.
Mais ce n'est pas le propos de la journée.
Nous sommes en pleine semaine spéciale micro expressions, et n'oubliez pas que dans la description il y a un lien vers la playlist qui regroupe toutes ces vidéos et il y a également un lien vers le livre de Paul Ekman,
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré pour écrire ces vidéos.
Nous avons vu la colère, la surprise, aujourd'hui on va passer au dégoût.
[générique]
Le dégoût, à ne pas confondre avec le mépris, est une émotion très puissante.
Et de fait, très dure à contrôler également.
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai invité Noam !
-Bonsoir !
[rires] -Ce n'est pas trop chelou cette phrase ? "Vous voulez être dégoûté, regardez la chaîne de ChicoNono&Co."
Non ! Quand même pas, quand même pas...
Aujourd'hui c'est différent, on va moins collaborer ensemble.
On va surtout regarder les expressions de ton visage, par rapport au dégoût.
Parce que tu avais fait une série de vidéos où tu mangeais des trucs chelous.
-Oui, des insectes, des insectes.
-Alors on va se référer à ce souvenir là pour regarder sur ton visage tout ce qu'il se passe, et après moi je vous en parle à coté.
La micro expression qui est elle-même liée au dégoût est un signe de rejet complet.
Soit de la personne qui est en face de vous, soit de ce qu'elle est en train de dire, soit d'un aliment qu'on a en face de nous ou alors même d'une situation.
-On a dégusté je crois... 4 trucs.
Et il y en avait un 5ème... C'était des grillons !
Et que je n'ai pas montré à la caméra parce que c'était dégueul****.
Les signes majeurs qui caractérisent le dégoût sont les narines qui remontent,
un peu... un peu comme ça,
un peu comme les vampires dans buffy, peut être qu'ils étaient juste dégoûtés de boire du sang... On ne sait pas !
Les muscles pyramidaux qui se contractent. En français ça donne:
les sourcils qui froncent comme dans la colère.
-Ouais... C'était vraiment dégeul****. [ralenti]
Une contraction au niveau du menton via le muscle de la houppe.
Tu l'as voit ma houppe ?
[ralenti]
Et bien sûr la lèvre supérieure qui se relève un petit peu.
Ne vous attendez pas à voir ça, comme ça...
Ça se relève, mais un petit peu.
Et ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que l'un des muscles qui sert à une autre micro expression sert aussi à celle-ci.
On y reviendra.
Lundi dans les commentaires, l'un d'entre vous m'a demandé quel intérêt on avait à voir les micro expressions.
En fait quel intérêt à voir que quelqu'un est en colère si ce n'est pour lui dire qu'il est en colère.
La question en soit n'est pas stupide.
Elle devient même très intéressante si on élargie.
Quel est l’intérêt de voir une micro expression ?
Vous allez voir la vraie expression des personnes à qui vous parlez.
Ce qui ne correspond pas forcément à l'aspect social que l'on se donne un petit peu comme un masque que l'on mettrai au dessus de ses vraies émotions.
Vous connaîtrez donc plus facilement la pensée réelle d'une personne.
Ça permet de détecter un mensonge, ça permet de détecter une chose qui est cachée, en tout les cas d'avoir une vérité émotionnelle.
Imaginons que je raconte à quelqu'un que je postule dans la même boite que lui, là où il travaille.
Un poste similaire.
Et que lui me réponde: "C'est génial, on va être collègue !"
Mais qu'à cet instant précis je vois passer une micro expression de colère.
Ça va me permettre de faire une supposition, attention pas une vérité. Une simple supposition.
On a jamais une vérité sur un seul signe.
L'hypothèse est donc qu'il n'apprécie pas que j'aille postuler dans la même boite que lui.
Ça l’énerve.
Alors peut être parce qu'il a peur que je prenne sa place ou simplement parce qu'il ne souhaite pas que j'aille là bas et que je vois certaines choses ou que je parle à certaines personnes
Je peux donc désamorcer la suite par précaution par exemple en lui disant:
"C'est super gentil parce que moi à ta place, ça ne m'aurais pas forcément plu donc je préfère venir t'en parler avant d'entamer les vraies démarches.
Dis moi franchement si ça te gène en quoi que ce soit et je comprendrai, vraiment."
Au cours de cette semaine je vous ai proposé tous les jours de vous concentrer sur des points clés et de les garder du coin de l'oeil.
Quand les muscles faciaux bougeront sur un quart de seconde, vous le verrez.
Vous y serez plus sensible.
Avant d'analyser il faut pouvoir détecter et c'est aussi le but de cette série.
Pour continuer en insérant le dégoût, ayez donc conscience du visage de l'autre,
et gardez un œil sur les lèvres, pincements, ouverture, levé de la lèvre supérieure.
Les sourcils en entiers pour la colère, le dégoût ou pour l'étonnement.
Les narines pour la dilatation et la remontée.
Les oeil pour l'écarquillement, et aujourd'hui on rajoute donc, le menton.
On est toujours dans cette zone, dans ce petit rectangle.
Merci beaucoup à ChicoNono qui est passé à Paris, il est passé prendre un café et donc je l'ai monopolisé lui aussi pour faire quelques exemples.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Pensez à la liker si elle vous a plu, c'est important.
Et allez voir les vidéos où tu manges des insectes. Je vous mettrai le lien aussi en fiche et dans la description.
Elle s'appelle comment cette vidéo ?
-Elle s'appelle... "dégustation d'insectes" je crois.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner au Mental Vlog.
Le défi du Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[générique de fin]